hey welcome to sanic spin 2006 oh boy
are we spinning
oh god that's creepy hey hey you wanna
pay some tricks
alright trigger warning trigger warning
it's gonna spin a lot alright if you get
motion sick you might throw up alright
so make sure that you haven't eaten
anything before you watch this how do
you even anything that's cool let's go
let's go next level yeah
this game actually looks like a sonic
tilde I just realized
okay the levels are getting harder and
so is the dildo
oh god [ __ ] hell this is disorienting
oh my god
I've always wanted to be a sonic penis
in space in the sky hey this is pretty
good here we go
oh god okay boy how is Sonic not kill
himself already god damn this is
horrible here we go goddamn I'm legit
starting to feel sick playing this game
honestly how do you breasts feel right
now I feel like the first time I played
a Sonic game arouse
god damn it I get so [ __ ] to eat
silly motions sake what I didn't do it
are you kidding me [ __ ] jump in the
circle you [ __ ] sonic [ __ ] there
we go thank you
oh hey hey look at that come on sanic is
that the winning sanic how did I do it
the other times I wanna fail Oh for
[ __ ] sake
wait that was it are you kidding me
I need more what the [ __ ]
when you run out of sanic there's only
one thing that you can do I'm sorry
father
I'm sorry I need to do it
um all right well let's move on to the
next game so this is a game about
putting stuff in your mouth so this is a
game that I can really relate to this is
some dank [ __ ]
oh god what the [ __ ] happened what just
happened what just happened Senna panda
oh my god this is [ __ ] disgusting I
love it keep putting [ __ ] in your mouth
holy [ __ ] this is the greatest game I
have never said that before so you know
it's legit put that banana inside you
all that tastes good tastes good that's
it baby
yeah that's the way I like yeah okay
wait lobster love to get in get in your
[ __ ] Oh God the Punta with a hamburger
can we do it come on Panda Oh get inside
my mouth baby crying oh God our shark no
it's a [ __ ] whale in a sausage at the
same time I have never enjoyed a game
this much eat it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
kill me the reason you clicked on the
video let's go one-night-stand we're
playing one night stand now I've never
had a one-night stand
yes mom that's sounding weird so I don't
know what to experience but it oh you
haven't you haven't either oh well let's
experience a one-night stand together
sounded weird again whatever let's do
this oh my head my stomach I feel great
oh all right so it's all blurry so it's
like a point and click game um I heard
our phone so let's got it nailed it
apparently I am [ __ ] Wilma from
scooby-doo and I can't see [ __ ] where my
glasses that a thing Wilma where my
glasses all these beauties destroying it
I don't care about your glasses Chanel
hilarious Gary
oh it's Gary Oaks let's lie [ __ ]
did we [ __ ] Gary from Pokemon that's
awesome
me what the hell happened to you
listening I have no idea but thanks a
lot for waking me up angry smiley face
this is how people will have wine
nightstands talk
how can anyone who types like this get
laid how can anyone who doesn't remember
to charge their [ __ ] phone get laid
what is this some kind of alternate
really verse what the [ __ ] it doesn't
make any sense why do all the idiots get
all the girls
ah except I got marks yeah okay we just
realized we're not in our room let's oh
oh we found another girl right next to
us
please be a woman or a she at least a
[ __ ] don't take a photo that don't
take sneak peeks of other people let's
wait crap we need answers
is it a boy is it a girl what's that
oh she ran away all right so what did we
do then we can explore her name is Robin
she's 22 I'll thank God somewhere around
somewhere a keen star just just cried a
single tear uh-oh she's coming oh oh hey
why does she look like an anime sorry
about dashing out of the room naked I
have at it yeah
why is this so awkward tell me duck why
is this so awkward Jesus Christ I'll
never have a one-night stand this is a
little awkward I'm playing a game and
I'm awkward Jesus Christ
- great excuse me I don't have time to
go to the bathroom and freshen myself up
I'm all right thank you
hi she's going to make us copy coffee
cool what snoop around her [ __ ]
panties Facebook page she has 67 friends
that doesn't seem like many what a total
loser I need to get out of here all
right I just had a cup of coffee I'm
feeling a bit better oh she's never
either had a one-night stand before
no she left again this is boring me to
death I want to see you again Robin I
really like you and I'd hate for us to
end up like this I mean we had this one
night again no but edit that out I did
not get stand out by a video game not
even video games huh not even in video
games you get up and leave the room
Robin see see to the front door and
waves keypad you look out on the street
and try to find a way home and we just
had a one-night stand
iris this is three free games with
parents that was six but that doesn't
matter thank you so much for watching
leave a like if you enjoyed and as
always as we do on this channel we kiss
the duck thank you for watching